the current F1 Champion Max verstappen
is a true gamer honestly it's a joke
it's not even you cannot call this an
event the clown show raging because you
dc'd out of a 24-hour race is honestly
pretty reasonable but a few weeks ago we
got to witness Max's true gamer Fury at
the golden toast GP everything seemed to
be going fine unfortunately while
heading into a corner Max got a little
nudge oh my goodness well oh dear oh
dear oh no red light if it's all each
other and it's verstappen that hits
Pinto now Max could have Shrugged it off
and finished the race with Grace it's
only a game after all right
here we go there's the statement yeah
Sven heartset was uh not the best friend
to match for Stafford after all of that
yes Max chose violence and barreled
towards that ramming him
off the track entirely like a trademark
racing gamer shortly after Max
disconnected and was disqualified never
change buddy